I have been so far off with recovery so
far and it's one of those under stated
just like nutrition is understated so
often we think we can outrun a bad diet
well you can't outrun recovery either
because the whole like like I keep
coming back to you is like why are you
training you're training to create a
greater stress on the body so the body's
like I have to adapt to that but if you
never give it time to adapt then you're
always going to be in a breakdown state
if you're in a breakdown State first
thing that goes is lean mass first thing
that goes up is inflammation and
oxidation and we know none of those are
good and viable for health so we look at
not only for health but if you're
someone who's competitive or want to do
some kind of like 5K 10K whatever it is
CrossFit open who knows you need
recovery in order to debt and get fitter
so if we're looking at recovery metrics
it doesn't mean necessarily sitting on
your butt and doing nothing but it's
that polarized super low intensity work
because if you're doing true high
intensity and Sprint interval you need
recovery because you can't do that every
day you can't go to the gym and be like
I'm going to do this every day your body
just won't allow you and you're going to
fall into that modern intensity tired
but wired sympathetically driven your
body's going to break down you're going
to put on belly fat you're going to go
what the hell is going on recovery is so
essential and as we get older we find we
need more recovery we see though on that
women are more endurance so when we're
looking at fatigue ability and endurance
when we're doing reps and sets in our
resistance training we we don't need as
much recovery between because our bodies
our muscles our muscle architecture is
less fatigable than men so we need a
little bit more of a dose response to
get adaptation but when we talk about
recovery from day to day we start to see
women need a little bit more because we
don't have the same kind of muscle
enzymes for fast twitch that men do our
bodies need a little bit more time to
absorb that hard training recover from
it before we can hit it hard again so I
tend to tell people like if you're
looking at a week and you're someone
who's like I always have lots of energy
at the beginning of the week and then it
starts to taper off it's like okay well
let's moderate that let's do like a
Monday evening session and maybe a
Tuesday Morning session and then
Wednesdays off and then maybe a Thursday
evening session Fridays off and then you
might do something on the weekend and
when I say off I mean really low
intensity and when you're doing a
session that's like your resistance
training or your Sprint so it's you're
trying to really like polarize where
you're putting it giving your body
adequate recovery and the reason why
you're bookending a Monday night and a
Tuesday morning is that Monday you're
sleeping in being able to deal with what
happens on a Monday and then you do your
hard session Monday night and then you
get another dose response by doing it
Tuesday morning so it compounds the
responses
better better stress some more there's
more adaptation needed because you've
kind of you put them so close together
but then you give yourself a bigger
block of a break yeah because then you
have all of twos the rest of Tuesday all
of Wednesday most of Thursday then you
hit Friday and then Friday is really
really hard again and your body can
handle it
yeah I'd be remiss though before I move
on to not ask about body recomposition
sort of puzzle of yeah like what's the
quickest way to do that to have a body
recomp and then I'm curious about like
bulking and cutting that's not something
that I've ever done I'm not sure it's
something I'd really love to do but it
seems like it's the sometimes the
quickest way to get certain results just
because you give yourself the adequate
nutrition to grow muscles but then have
sort of cuts so what's the what's the
most efficient way to
maintain and grow lean body mass but
then reduce body fat when we're looking
at you had the key factor there like
eating to build your muscle because so
many women don't eat enough and you need
abundance to actually build muscle right
so you're doing your heavy resistance
training and for women we know that when
you're doing heavy resistance training
especially like squats and deadlifts it
increases the mobilization of abdominal
fat so by the nature of actually doing
resistance training you're helping body
recomp so if you're doing your build
phase right and you're polarizing like I
just said like the double dose and then
another hard one so you can actually get
harder then we look strategically to do
one Sprint interval maybe on Wednesday
night
and we have a slight calorie restriction
every night so when we're looking at
what are we doing okay we're going to
take out maybe
150 to 200 calories every night but only
over the course of one block of training
so you build and you're like I gotta cut
okay how am I going to cut well we keep
our resistance training and we add in
one Sprint interval session to really
top in like create a dish a different
stress and then we have a very slight
calorie restriction so the lineup so
you're bulking and cutting within the
week yep
and then the other thing is really
upping that protein
so we see that when you're in a calorie
deficit if you are maintaining that 1.1
to 1.2 grams per pound
you strip body fat and you keep your
lean mass so women who are eating a lot
and they're like yeah I need protein
protein protein it's like it's really
hard pressed even with my Olympic
lifters they're still not eating enough
protein to get that muscle because it's
really hard to think about how much
protein you need to eat because they're
like what do you mean I need 150 to 160
grams a day it's like well that's what
you need to build it and to and to
loosen the body fat so protein becomes
really important there is a study I've
been talking about recently because a
friend of mine from
um Flora he posted it and he's like look
at this really cool study on protein and
they took
um normal weight but obese women so you
know like skinny fat and there was this
big cohort and they split them and none
of them were doing exercise they're just
normal daily life they split them and
all they did was increase the protein
intake in one group to 1.6 grams per
kilo so that's just right around that
0.8 to 0.9 grams yeah and then the the
other group maintained their normal
which was like 0.8 grams per kilo so
what is that point
five per pound ish or maybe a little bit
less over the course of 12 weeks no
exercise people with a higher protein
intake completely recomp their body no
exercise same calories too same calories
okay got it they just no calorie change
macro adjustment yep exactly
so protein is so powerful when you're
bumping it up and your body's like oh
look at this I can build lean mass I
don't need to store fat because I can
build lean I have the building blocks
yes exactly so you know we talk about
exercise and resistance training being
the key all but if you don't have
adequate protein you're not going to
maximize that and you're not going to
recomp
so protein super important and then as
far as for those people who don't
consume animal protein like yourself
what what are your best tips to get
enough protein wide variety wide variety
of fruits veggies I know people like
what veggies protein peas green peas
lots of protein in there right and Nami
we look at nuts and seeds we look at
sprouted grain breads Bread's good
especially a lot of protein and sprouted
green breads tempeh for fermentation I'm
not a fan of tofu primarily because I
can't handle soy but I don't find it a
really fantastic source of protein I'd
rather err on the side of tempeh because
you have more bang for your buck or
looking at nutrient density
um and then yeah and there's times and
places when you're really trying to up
your protein where you have to
supplement and that's just part of it
like you can't eat enough
yeah yeah yeah yeah so don't be afraid
to implement it it's there to use let's
finish off with just sort of like a
little bit of a wake-up call of the of
birth for birth control because I feel
like it's one of the things that in the
general population is getting a lot of
awareness to its um detriment everything
from uh you know disrupting you're not
having a real cycle and having a
withdrawal bleed which I didn't even
know until a few years ago because I
took birth control for 16 years
um to every to even
the studies showing that women that are
on contraceptive oral contraceptive or
birth control are choosing different men
than if they weren't on birth control
they choose more feminine men when
they're on birth control than when
they're off so essentially if you've got
a if you if your woman has is on birth
control you're together and then she
gets off of it she might not like you
yep I know it's strange isn't it it is
and I just think about the poor side
effect of it reducing testosterone
correct it reduces testosterone in in
women as well which I think I took it
for my whole career so essentially this
is what was happening with my much
needed like
my job yeah when we look at OCS and
the combined oral contraceptive pill
right so when we look at it there's so
many different formulations
when we're looking at the progestin
component that's the important part this
is where we start to see that you have a
lot of aggression depending on what if
it's more androgenic so this is why the
studies are coming out it's like if a
woman's on an OC and she's looking for a
more effeminate man it's because she
feel the androgenicity of that progestin
is making her like really aggressive and
it's like yeah okay I want to be the
alpha in the in the relationship here
we look from performance metrics and we
look at the estrogen and the
progesterone component so we know that
if someone is using a 30 microgram dose
of estradiol in their oral contraceptive
pill it builds Muscle really easily but
there's no strength that accompanies
that muscle bulk weird so it's like why
do I want to build more muscle fibers
when it doesn't actually make me
stronger if we look at 20 microgram dose
it doesn't really do anything different
than naturally cycling
we look at oxidative stress it's much
higher just across the board for women
who are taking oral contraceptive pill
we see inflammation factors much higher
for women using it across the board
and we also see that screening
schematics change so we know that if we
are looking at training really really
hard it's the first five days of the
active fill where you can push hard and
recover well
and it's the last five days of the
placebo pill that you can train really
really hard and recover well because
when you're on it it's not like you have
this steady state dose you have a peak
and a trough every day which is why 10
days from the start of your bleed
essentially ish until five days in five
days after ish so when we look at the
modernization of medicine and scientific
design it was a point where men were
like women are have smaller brains and
they're delicate flowers and they don't
know anything so when we look at like
how things evolved it's all been through
that male lens so scientific design has
always been through the male lens and I
mean it was a point not too long ago
where women going through perimenopause
or putting insane asylums because no one
understood what was going on
and if you look retrospectively almost
all the women that were killed as
witches in the Salem Witch Hunt were
women who were perimenopausal because of
hot flashes and mood disorders so people
like primarily men are like these women
are crazy and they're witches so there's
a long history of the male lens on all
of this stuff so we look specifically at
scientific design originally it was male
rats and it was CIS men and that model
is broken people are seeing that it's
broken we see things like Ambien you
know it stays in a women's system a lot
longer so people like gosh what the hell
so medical community even though it was
like in the 90s that NIH said you can't
just use male rats you can't just use
men but it's just in the past four to
five years where people are like oh my
gosh yeah really we have to use women
and I will say one benefit of the covid
pandemic is the outcomes between women
and men in the vaccine and the vaccine
rates and the success in the vaccine
what was that I don't even know that
statistic it was better for women women
got less sick and they had less time
being sick than men and then they're
looking now at long covid and
unfortunately it's reversed but now
people are really going what's going on
if that happened then there are sex
differences so if if it was not that
case if men did better than women never
would have been the conversation but
because women did better than men on the
vaccine it made so many people globally
in the medical community look up and be
like what
and then in sports science and nutrition
I've been in this for oh gosh a couple
of decades but it's really just been in
the past four or five years where we've
had you know like Don Scott who's been
tracking menstrual cycle on the U.S
soccer team coming out and saying hey
we've had better outcomes when we're
tracking the menstrual cycle and people
are like what what do you mean and so
it's been feeding forward back into the
scientific Community you have to clean
up that scientific design and include
women if you like this clip and you want
to hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen